and what's been the scalable or workable
uh system and what's been the most
privileged aspect of it and what's been
the most challenging aspect
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
our next guest is grace nolan samsung's
vp of integrated marketing for their
home
entertainment division grace oversees
consumer
retail and trade marketing across the
television audio
and consumer i.t businesses she leads
the way in cultivating foundational
partnerships
for the ustv business with xbox netflix
and espn and instilled a brand mission
to lead through service to gamers
streamers and sports fans in pursuit of
their passions
and according to our back to school
study 75 percent of gen z
responders are saying that they
influence their parents
purchasing habits and particularly in
tech
grace i'm hoping you can share a little
bit more about that
i would like to hi hi grace how are you
by the way i'm great how are you all
good on the record i know her survey
says 75
i'm i gary vaynerchuk believe it's 100
it is fascinating to watch uh kids
voices
in homes compared to 30 40 years ago
grace great to have you i hope you and
your family are well
um there was something when i was uh you
know the team does an incredible job
for me prepping for these but i'm 100
improv
but out of respect because i'm like man
they put in so much work
i i started feeling you know i took this
vacation and i'm like how can i be
better i'm like i feel a little guilt
that the team puts in so much work hours
and hours for these things and then i
come on and just
wing it and there so i decided to glance
i've gone from nothing
to a glance and in that glance i saw
that samsung's talking a lot about
adding boundaries
families adding boundaries uh ad
boundaries during this time
transforming their homes i thought that
was super fascinating and was dying
couldn't wait to get to you and hear
what that meant and what you're seeing
so let's start there
okay so first of all i think it's
awesome that you don't listen to your
team and you go off
on the rails because i'm the same way
and it's
amazing it's very liberating so i'm with
you
um and by the way on a record that that
has
nothing to do with my team that is my
own personal shortcomings i think it's
your strength
but my shortcomings so my team's and i'm
sure your teams are legit but go ahead
fire away 100 no my team is all smarter
than me but
you know whatever anyway um so let's
talk about boundaries
um it's really like cobit has like
brought so many insights to our team
you don't realize in a typical day how
many
rooms and environments that you go
through right so like imagine you wake
up in your room you travel through your
house to get out the door
you like go to the gym and then you go
you know grab a coffee and you go to
work or your kids go to school
and that night you might go to dinner at
a restaurant and
basically covet happened and all those
rooms and environments went away every
single one of them
right like no more movie theaters no
more anything and then you were home
in the same house with your family 24
hours a day
and people really started i mean we
were as animals humans adapt
and we started pivoting and really
leaning towards technology and
our screens had a huge role in that so
they started looking to us for
entertainment for
learning for fitness for all of those
things to take
the place of movie theaters and your
office and your classroom
um and it was really cool because i feel
like when you talk about technology
you know people get so tied up in
features
and that's not why we exist right like
this to us was not like a just a
business opportunity but it was a call
to service
like a reminder of our purpose to create
technology to help people and we we like
we we came to task man like we had like
probably the coolest thing that we
launched um was the
outdoor tv which wasn't supposed to
launch for months later
and we're like people are canceling
their vacations they're no longer
getting on planes and going to spain or
going
you know like they're not even going to
the shore because who knows what the
airbnb
situation is going to be right right so
how do we create that experience in your
backyard
how do you start entertaining people in
open spaces and we el
like we escape escalated and advance
the launch of this product so that we
could create an additional room
in your space um but we did that with
the the content in our tvs with
we did that with new tvs coming out with
our lifestyle brand
i mean it's been a it's just been a
tremendously challenging
time but very cool right like
this is why we exist totally understand
um i'm just gonna get to the thing
that's super on my mind what was the
thing that ryan reynolds did
can you help me here like i don't have
all the context but it's like
like seemed super interesting and he's
always super clever so
just to educate the audience on what
happened and and me myself
on that matter yeah no it was cool that
was probably one of our more fun
projects
um what a what a talented guy
so we were working with netflix last
year we have a ton of really great
partners and we were sponsoring
um a you know the launch of their new
movie 600 grand which featured ryan
reynolds
and we were thinking as a team we've
been working with adam and eve
our creative agency and we're
brainstorming like what can we do with
ryan that you know you know could
elevate our our
you know interactions with with this
younger audience and honestly
he's like as a-list as a guest right
like i can't afford him
so we're like what if we did something
with aviation gin
we brought him on we pitched an idea he
didn't respond we're like it's dead
and then he came back all of a sudden
was like oh this is kind of funny but
why don't we change it to do this
and honestly it was the fastest i think
we've ever moved and we move at the
speed of technology like we're fast
everything we do is fast
um but we turned around everything
probably within a week
so finalizing scripts getting all the
approvals
all the way it's like with a gym company
so this has to go like all the way up to
our ceo
and our risk people and everybody and we
had to produce it
shoot it and ship it out and it was just
awesome and what a fun team um so yeah
we got it out we got
over a million um you know
interactions likes comments on twitter
within probably
a day so just a lot of yeah it was very
cool
let's go back to the back-to-school
theme theme where
where is samsung seeing its kind of
intersection with education like
purchasing trends um you know what what
are you seeing like what
what kind of insights can you give us in
the audience
yeah so here's the thing covet hit and
when situations like a global pandemic
you know because we've all been through
like seven or eight of them
um when they happen people just start
holding on to their wallets right they
get nervous
and we were completely setting ourselves
up for
for some slowness for some you know
softness within our business
and all of a sudden we started seeing
the category grow
and it was growing and growing faster
and then it's honestly
to date it's been growing in the pretty
impressive double digits for a flat
category it was
a surprise but the reason was because
again the boundaries the rooms you know
people were having their
kids from college come back and they
needed another screen for the second
bedroom or the third bedroom
they needed a new screen because they're
trying to learn from
their virtual classroom and teachers
don't present off with powerpoint
right like it's not like they have a
beautiful like 20 font
screens for the kids to look at on their
their their mobile devices you know
they're writing
and you cannot make out a thing and so
they're casting
onto bigger screens students are casting
onto bigger screens
and and and you know parents who are
trying to balance their own work
with what their kids were doing were
also buying an extra screen so that they
could keep an eye out
on what it is that their kid was
watching while they were trying to work
so i mean it's it's everybody's changed
everything has changed and everything
that they're doing right now
is to make things work we all thought
that this was going to be temporary
and now we're settling in for another
round of it in the fall um
so what are the ways that that you know
technology brands and brands in general
can
help parents that's the only that's the
only you know
consistent question that we're asking
ourselves what else can we do
beyond hardware you know there are
things that we can do with
ui right so we have free content we have
content for kids we have
child protect protected um you know
features so that
sometimes you're using the tv as a
babysitter and they're not being set
free
i mean the ipad and and and the and the
and the television have become an
incredible
babysitter for many yeah but how can you
curate that experience with your tv
to be not just paw patrol 24 hours a day
which is
what my kids would do let's talk right
so let's let's
so let's talk about connected everything
i think something that you
you know that samsung has done extremely
well is that
you know internet of things connectivity
across the board because that will allow
you to curate better
thoughts on that and kind of the
advancements you've been making in that
universe
yeah so i we've been doing this
connected home thing for years
yep um i think what we're trying to do
is
take it way past incremental to
completely change the role of the tv
so what we've been seeing in years past
is like okay i can connect my watch to
my phone i can
maybe connect that experience to my tv
and connect
you know some of the content that we're
seeing you know within the screen so
that it's a little bit easier to
aggregate
we're kind of doing it all so it's all
going to just blow up the incremental
little
lines are going to go away and then
everything is going to be connected so
you know we talk about you know changing
the role of tvs right so it's not just
about
finding a show to watch on friday night
now it's about saying what your
preference is for how you're going to
spend your friday night
so maybe you're going to be working out
maybe you're going to be meditating
maybe you're going to be watching a
movie or binging a series
and the tv our universal guide now
offers all of that
right so it offers various genres of
content
various levels of interactivity with the
content it's no longer just a one way
you taking a show absorbing the show
eating popcorn and then turning it off
and going right
now you can do things with the tv and
imagine you can do even more in the
future and that that's really our vision
but you know one of the things that we
do
is to take that experience and elevate
the
the ease with which you're consuming
that content right so
you know when you think about going to
the movies it's not just
the movie itself that's great
or bad that makes you have a good or bad
experience right so
it's how good the movie is how
comfortable your seat was
in the theater you know whether the
sound and the quality of the
the visual experience was good getting
to the theater
whether there was traffic and the
decision
on which movie to pick before you got to
the theater
like all of those things impact the
quality of your
date night right at the end of that
night so samsung is saying like forget
all that stuff
let's just make everything easier let's
give you a kick-ass screen with an
amazing audio setting
let's give you an aggregator a universal
guide that says okay we know you like
these things
let me aggregate your content across the
entire universe
of content so it's not just it's like
netflix on steroids right so netflix
will take all their content and say
hey you like this type of content go
watch this
samsung's tv will take the content
across ott
broadcast a world of content including
our own free channels and say
hey go watch this tonight and we're
going to do it on a kick-ass screen
and we're going to take all the
decision-making away and we're just
giving you a great experience
there's that piece of connectivity um
and then i think
probably the other really interesting
piece and i think i just
i apologize yeah i uh i want to get this
in and we're going to run out of time
because it's by far
ah sorry no no sorry nothing i'm sorry
but i gotta get this thing because i
think it's gonna bring a ton of value
and i think
it's a really cool thing to talk about
you are
a dynamo and i'm sure everybody's seeing
it i'm reading the comments
you've got a lot of things going on and
you are going through all of this
with three children at home i think it'd
just be fun back to like me trying to
always find a fun potpourri of like
different things that might bring value
talk about on a personal level like
you know how you're navigating this with
three what are the ages like what's been
the dynamics what's been the highlight
what's been the low light and what's
been the scalable
or workable uh system and what's been
the
most privileged aspect of it and what's
been the most challenging aspect
so okay i'm so glad you don't mind
giving me an excuse to talk about my
kids because i love my kids
everybody loves
i don't know if i wanted to go here but
i was like you know what this will help
so many people and i just
was feeding off your energy i'm like
[ __ ] she's gonna go there
yeah i'll go there i mean my kids are
awesome i you know we did this little
promo and they were like we're gonna be
famous like oh
you're gonna be so famous legit
um but so my kids i have three kids
there i have two boys seven and five um
my five-year-old just graduated from
pre-k yesterday so
and then i have a two-year-old little
girl um and like
honestly i think i'm a really grateful
person in general
so i like hope it happened and we're
like oh my god we got so lucky
and the reason we got so lucky is
because we had just moved and we're like
oh good thing we got into
this house before covid and i was
traveling a ton for work and i was like
wow i guess
i get to not miss all these really cool
things happening in my kids lives
and also i have an amazing husband
right like brian brando and kudos
like i'm lucky to have that
infrastructure and
i'm lucky to have a support network with
my family like i know that those are all
those are all points of privilege um and
i and i'm
every day just grateful that we're all
surviving together but yeah
it's it's a balancing act right like my
kids they will come
into meetings be like i don't like that
like in a creative review with an agency
you'd be like
okay that's enough guys like that's
really cute go away
and we're making it work but we're doing
it the same way everyone is doing it
and there's nothing there's nothing
special it's just we're grateful to have
those moments
what's been the funniest thing
the funniest thing like did the like the
five-year-old like poop on you while you
were on a zoom with executives like
literally the funniest thing what is the
funniest thing
oh there's a couple things um there have
been meetings that have been
um walked in on pantless
and with little kid pantless also
oftentimes mean
underwear lists that's right there were
a couple of those occasions
um really really loud
fighting in the background or funny
jokes fart jokes
there was a comment about dynamic
flatulence in a meeting that was a total
joke and you could hear
like it was just it's just there's a lot
of it it's constant
it's fun though and it's cool to work
for a company where
everybody's just kind of like yeah you
know that's yeah that's just what's
happening it's cool
yeah thank you thank you for your
incredible energy grace
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon